[Music]
hey guys
i haven't done an unboxing and review
video in a very long time
so it is time today is all about
sneakers now we know life cannot always
be perfect
but your sneakers can be and that's why
today i'm unboxing one of the best
sneaker brands out there olivier
cabell let's check them out
[Music]
all right guys i'm so excited because i
bought these two pairs from olivier
cabell yes it's not a sponsored video
but then they also sent me this for free
which is pretty neat
jewelry all right so i got these two
pairs the first one
wow man this is so light exactly what i
wanted
this is the phoenix white sneakers
and then we got the stylish low one
black sneakers
nice all right guys i'm gonna try these
shoes on for a couple of weeks and while
i do
i'm going to tell you a few things about
olivier cabell that you need to know
let's do this first up the phoenix white
now the phoenix white is 3d printed from
seven recycled water bottles
and it's made so that you can wash it in
the washing machine
and these guys got free shipping
worldwide
now i've been testing it out for a while
and they're great they look stylish
fits in with most outfits and it feels
super light
comfortable and cooler what more do you
want
well if you don't like the white you can
also get it in black
now let's take a look at the low one
black snake these sneakers
will never get out of style because they
always look
great hand stitched and lasted in italy
with cough skin leather on top and
margum italian outsoles
well known for its great quality rubber
good quality shoes will always
be better than low quality shoes that
won't last long
comfortable stylish and fits with most
of the outfits
if you need a new pair of good quality
sneakers then check olivia cabell
out they are the king of sneakers with a
lot more styles that you can choose from
for men and women they've been in forbes
esquire
gq the new york times and many others
all that and they're
only two years old it started by a guy
named scott
and his wife their main goal was to
bring simplicity quality construction
and timeless design to the fitware space
and they've certainly
achieved it a lot of my favorite shoes
for in the video description down below
if you want to check them out
now if you guys want more unboxing
videos let me know what kind of products
you guys
like me to unbox and i'll see if i can
also throw in a few
free giveaways as well that's it from me
guys i'll see you in the next video
cheers